[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by carlson young the
writer director and star of the blazing
world which is out today in select
theaters and on demand how you doing
today carlson i'm very well thank you
so i absolutely love this film i was
really really excited to see it being
that i was getting a lot of praise at
the sundance film festival um what was
really cool about this was that you know
you originally did a short of this film
and now you're doing this feature debut
as a director which is really exciting
but were you always planning to be the
star of it as well or was that kind of
intimidating to be like oh it's the
first film i'm directing but also
happening to star and was that like a
lot
it was intimidating but i
sort of always
felt really drawn to the character and
and i i look back and there are just
sort of nuances that i don't know if i
could have articulated to
another actor so i felt really
comfortable wearing all the hats with
this one in particular
yeah and i mean it's amazing how
impressive you do all of the hats and
it's exciting because i feel like
horror directors and anything horror is
like the rock stars of the film industry
right now so it's always exciting to see
a new one on the scene like yourself um
but you're really good at doing jump
scares which i think a lot of people
struggle at first
do you have a specific strategy for that
or any advice you can give aspiring our
directors and how you kind of go about
timing jump scares
oh man you know i mean i'm okay at them
i think i'll get better but
i just
i always just sort of
if it scares me on the day like i think
it's a little bit
tricky to leave that to post which i
think is really tempting because
once you get some color and sound design
and and and uh score in there i think
that that really comes to fruition so
just like making sure that the bones are
there so that when you get to post it's
like very fun to crack okay that that's
interesting you mentioned two color
because that was one of the things that
stood out to me about this film and i
loved was the colors so
when you're deciding that though writing
in the writing and directing process
where are you mapping out how you're
going to
like set that scene is that in the
writing process or is that yes
absolutely it was it wasn't um it wasn't
in the script writing process but it was
very much an early
conceptualization of these sets and i
worked really closely with our
production designer
to
you know
and dp shane kelly to talk
through every single color that was to
be used and i was really relating color
to chakra and energy and um you know the
red orb like representing you know the
root of
the root chakra and the root of her
trauma and her creator color and
yeah so i mean every little detail like
that is is really specific and i put a
lot of thought into something oh no
that's amazing to even hear that and
that's just showing that effort you put
in that yeah everything does count in
your film visually and like you also
mentioned about sound design but another
thing that stood out to me i loved the
score it was very like shining inspired
to me
yeah and um absolutely i love the sound
cues you had because i felt like moments
where there was something important
happening there was like a hit of a
piano 100 you know
so and the computer was my husband so
there was no boundaries we had a very
candid dialogue
um about what would and wouldn't work
and so yeah we just sat there and it was
just like
you know like each little thing i wanted
it to come off very theatrical and very
like like a ballet you know it starts
it starts in in the nutcracker and it
starts in tchaikovsky and it and it ends
with you know panda bears tchaikovsky
sample and like i just thought that was
like oh my god like this is like a
ballet and i want it to feel i want this
score to punctuate
every emotion
like like a ballet you know yeah
no and it totally came off the way that
that totally caught my ears if that
makes sense and it's interesting too
because i wonder with you having so much
thought into this with all these parts
of the puzzle here to make a film like
this are you someone when the editing is
happening do you have to be there are
you are you a helicopter person or you
kind of let them do their thing how do
you kind of well i let our you know our
editor was amazing james crouch and he
put together an assembly of the film as
we were shooting so
when we wrapped i literally went
straight to the edit and had an assembly
to look at and then from there yes i'm a
very helicopter
from there but i want to see like what
your interpretation is and then we'll
like go back you know oh sure sure and
and it's interesting too because i like
to that i thought the jump cuts really
worked well because i think that shows
it was confident filmmaking where i feel
like
a lot of people are scared to do jump
cuts you know like it's it's this scary
thing but i know i thought it worked and
i thought there was a rhythm to the film
so
do you feel like though strategically
that should be something that people
should balance out and use sparingly or
do you think oh yeah go crazy with jump
cuts like what's your view on jump cuts
well oh gosh i mean
i love a jump cut i think you just
i think you know
i think once you sort of
can sit back and have more of a
bird's-eye view um
for
what is actually being not only conveyed
in the scene but like what kind of
performance you've performances you've
gotten from the actors and then and then
knowing like
you know picking your moments to like
chop and screw it you know in an
interesting and compelling way hopefully
so yeah
yeah no it really comes off that way and
i i really appreciate them cause i like
that anything that's making me feel like
i'm seeing something different i like
and
you know
there's some heavy material in this film
there's heavy monologues in this film so
going into that writing process for you
because you're writing this with
somebody else how comfortable do you
have to be with your writing partner to
write scenes like that you have to be
really comfortable pierce um my
co-writer pierce brown is obviously very
well versed in the fantasy space and
someone i respect really deeply as a
friend and a writer is one of my uh
first friends that i ever had really
when i moved to los angeles and um so
he's a really close friend and
we were able to
really speak a language together because
we love the same [ __ ] and because we're
really good friends so yeah yeah
okay so it is neces you have to have a
comment right because i think you know
yeah that that makes sense um
also too i always wonder this but you
know you're starring in this movie
you're acting in a scene but when you're
in a scene with your scene partner
is there is it like are you able to turn
off the director part of your head like
are you judging their performance while
you're acting with them or do you kind
of have to separate like how the only
time
the only scene that i felt like
i had no trouble turning that part off
in my brain for the for the other actor
the only time that i kind of remember
like i was like not i was like like i
was like fully on the monitor and like
not really in the scene with them was
the woods um was this sort of a whole
interlude part of it like when because
there was there was a lot of people in
the scene
so i'm just like i i'm sorry
over here like looking you know that was
the only
um that was the only one that was like
there was just a little bit of
you know there was a shift of energy
that needed to happen i just needed to
be on the monitor and not
not in the scene
yeah no that that makes sense um
and it's so impressive because like
you're saying you're wearing all these
hats
and i think what's gonna happen now is
that
people will get attached to new horror
directors and then they want you to just
i know it's fantasy too but like if they
like it they're gonna want you to keep
doing horror so
in your plans do you want to keep doing
is it your favorite genre is fantasy
your favorite channel like what is your
kind of or
horror fantasy
is my favorite genre
um
through and through uh
i'm yeah i'm not like as inspired by
like
quiet indeed dramas like not really um
so i yeah i'm but but at the same time
like i think this is a really good
mission statement this is like what i
love
here are my
inspirations like this is the [ __ ] that
i think is cool and then refining it
from there you know
and it was this was my first one out of
the gate it was a really challenging one
to make i'm i'm i'm
just blown away that we even got to make
it during this time so
that's something i'm really grateful for
but
oh yeah like
i can't wait to do more more
sure and is every ounce of this project
coming out of love from you like is do
you is this really would you consider a
passion project like this is
part of you
oh yeah i keep telling people i'm like i
didn't know
but i made like a horcrux
like
out of my soul
right
right
yeah wow that's that's
that's awesome but yeah put a little
piece
yeah hell yeah and you know my last
question for you before i let you go is
that speaking of like passion and love
but you're doing these three things so
well with writing directing and acting
if you had to say what is your true love
out of those three what where is your
soul
oh gosh that is such a hard question
because they're so
intertwined like they they all feel so
but i one thing i will say
is i crave and just really deeply desire
the creative control
that you get as a writer and director
hell yeah
i love that so everybody it's out today
in select theaters and on demand it's
the blazing world go see it carlson
young does something brilliant here it's
a it's amazing film it's visually
beautiful to watch and like i said it's
such fun sound stuff going on there's so
much going on so i have to watch it
again to take it all in which i
appreciate i like deep stuff like that
so carlson thank you so much for joining
me today and i hope to talk to you in
the future yeah definitely have a great
rest of your day